c'est dans le ciel
[Musique]
patrice michaud est fier de son
quatrième album sorti juste à temps pour
la reprise des spectacles toute façon ça
aurait été un coup d'épée dans l'eau de
sortir un disque dans les derniers moore
mois vu la nature de l'artiste que je
suis
arrivé sur la scène avant d'arriver sur
disque effects et pour je gère d'aller
défendre ces chansons là un spectacle
la rentrée musicale et historique à
cause de son abondance ça se bouscule au
portillon chez les musiciens car un
disque est une carte de visite pour
vendre le biais de concerts ajoutez à
cela que pour nicola ciccone la pandémie
aura été une source d'inspiration
je nous imagine
comblé et heureux
je trouve ça positif qui en plus c'est
logique parce que les artistes créent
quand ça va moins bien il crée quand ils
se sentent impuissants je pense que face
à la pandémie les questionnements
étaient multiples fait que c'est juste
normal qu'ils aient beaucoup d'artistes
qui
pour le groupe sal barbe et comme tant
d'autres le confinement aura un effet
été un moteur de création jorane a
réalisé un album grandiose
on m'a toujours dit que la rentrée
c'était toujours très chargé mais là
c'est encore plus que d'habitude mais
c'est normal en fait on a tous été dans
nos cocon en même temps alors tous les
papillons sortent en même temps
comment savoir ce coeur qui bat face à
ce foisonnement le choix sera déchirant
tant pour le public que pour les
chroniqueurs il ya des beaux albums qui
vont probablement tomber dans les
craques effectivement il ya un tri qui
doit sera comme chroniqueuse culturelle
oui se trouve qu'il ya beaucoup
j'ose pas dire qu'ils ont eu trop parce
qu'il y aura toujours je suis persuadé
qu'il ya toujours un public pour le
matériel
[Musique]
les mélomanes devront donc faire leurs
recherches pour trouver l'album qui
musée qu'à leurs oreilles ici louis
philippe ouimet radio canada bon rien
ici
[Musique]